I kind of want to be a playmate actually
this seems like a really good life I
play a playmate in my upcoming movie I
was inspired by the girls next door but
I'm not exactly playing a specific
person my characters she's just not
nearly as savvy as a lot of those girls
are so my character is based purely out
of my own imagination my original vision
was much darker for the movie then after
sort of experiencing the mansion itself
and shooting there and the whole
lifestyle is it's pretty amazing it is
just as surreal as it seems there's
animals everywhere and these hot girls
everywhere our men in silk robes it's
pretty great
your cocktail and I love Bugs Bunny but
my favourite money has to be Pamela
Anderson I've done two movies now with
Pamela and I adore helping you guys I
love Sarah Silverman I love parker posey
love Tina Fey Molly Shannon those are
definitely people that I really admire
my first Melanie Hollywood award it was
my Stoney from high time which I have on
my mantle it's a big bomb and I love it
my parents are really proud of me every
movie I've done I've loved for different
reasons in the scary movies was such an
incredible education for me you know
even little things like learning how to
hit your mark or what a set etiquette is
and I think it gave me a huge sort of
just basic education and doing those
movies which gave me a little confidence
just friends was so much fun because I
got to feel so wild and obnoxious and I
guess I was tapping into an evil part of
me haha but it was very intimidating to
be on the set of lost in translation in
Brokeback Mountain
I was scared on my mind I thought
they're gonna fire me there's no if it's
continued on with this my craziness
there was no difference between working
with Anglian
Brothers